nous avons travaillé pour faire en sorte
d'assumer et d'assurer à la sécurité
sociale qui est encore ce bien commun de
tous les français un avenir
[Musique]
nous avons profondément remanié le
projet du gouvernement tout simplement
parce que c'est un projet qui accumule
les déficits nous allons enregistrer sur
ce plfss
pratiquement 22 milliards d'euros et si
on ne fait rien on risque finalement de
nuire et de disloquer cette sécurité
sociale
[Musique]
je voudrais vous donner un certain
nombre d'exemples promise et les
retraites et même macron aurait été le
premier président de la république
depuis 30 ans maintenant à ne pas
assumer une réforme des retraites on
voit bien que aujourd'hui en france il
ya une paupérisation des retraités la
retraite complémentaires du privé
l'agirc-arrco a décidé de sourds
revaloriser les retraites parce qu'il ya
là aussi un problème de déficit la seule
façon finalement veut pas pour périz est
à la fois nos retraités mais aussi les
plus jeunes générations sur lesquels
vont reposer tous ces déficits c'est de
repousser l'âge légal de départ en
retraite c'est ce que nous avons fait
avec un âge légal de 64 ans deuxième
exemple qui est aussi extrêmement
important
la branche familiale vous savez que
depuis que françois hollande à
détricoter une politique familiale
notamment à travers le quotient familial
à travers les allocations familiales qui
ont été soumis à des conditions de
ressources et bien il y a eu un
effondrement de la natalité nous avons
perdu en un peu plus de dix ans près de
100 mille naissances par an il faut
désormais restaurer cette politique
familiale parce que c'est l'avenir de
notre pays puis le troisième exemple que
je voudrais vous c'est l'exemple de
l'hôpital on appris il ya quelques jours
que un lit sur cinq étaient fermés dans
l'hôpital public en france alors même
qu' il y a le ségur de la santé le ségur
de la santé c'est beaucoup d'argent
public sans doute en faut-il c'est sur
2022 l'an prochain près de 12 milliards
d'euros en plus et pourtant ça
fonctionne toujours moins bien un moment
donné quand le système ne fonctionne pas
parce que par exemple il est trop
bureaucratisé plus d'argent public ça
conduit finalement à croître tous ces
blocages donc que nous allons faire une
commission denquête parce que le sujet
est grave nous voulons étudier pendant
les cinq ou six prochains mois pour
proposer des vraies solutions peut-être
faut-il de l'argent public par exemple
pour mieux rémunérer le personnel
soignant mais il faut aussi encore une
fois faire en sorte qu' on puisse
replacer les médecins au coeur de la
gestion de l'hôpital plutôt que le
personnel administratif et puis on doit
aussi replacer le patient au coeur de
notre système de soins il y a trop de
déserts médicaux en france il y a cinq
millions et demi de français qui n'ont
plus de médecin traitant